LIDIA, THANKS IT IS CHAOS LEAVE
IT TO NEW YORK.
AINSLEY, TAKE IT AWAY.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU, BRIAN
CHICAGO’S MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
SAYS CHICAGO POLICE WILL BE
VACCINATED AS THE UNION FIGHTS
THE MANDATE.
LISTEN.
>> NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH IN
2020 OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
COVID-19, NOTHING ELSE.
IT’S FOOLISH, FOOLISH TO BE
TRYING TO TAKE A VICTORY LAP
WHEN SO MUCH IS AT STAKE, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT’S IN KEEPING
, WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE.
THEY WILL BE VACCINATED.
AINSLEY: THIS AS THE CITY SEES
YET ANOTHER VIOLENT WEEKEND WITH
40 PEOPLE SHOT AND THREE KILLED
SINCE FRIDAY.
HERE TO REACT IS PRESIDENT OF
THE CHICAGO FRATERNITY OF POLICE
, JOHN CATSENZARA.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU HEAR HE SAY POLICE WILL
BE VACCINATED?
>> WELL IT’S RHETORIC WE’VE
HEARD FROM DAY ONE, THE IRONY IS
SHE TALKS ABOUT HER OFFICERS
THAT HAVE DIED FROM COVID.
THANKFULLY WE HAVEN’T HAD AN
OFFICER PASS AWAY FOR ALMOST
A YEAR NOW SO CLEARLY, WE’VE
ADJUSTED TO OUR NEW REALL
REALITY.
THIS ISN’T DIMINISHING THEIR
MEMORY BECAUSE WE’LL BE HAVING A
FORMAL MEMORIAL FOR THOSE
OFFICERS WE LOST LAST
YEAR AT THE FOP THIS WEEK BUT
FOR HER TO TALK ABOUT OFFICERS
IN THE LINE OF DUTY IS
DISGUSTING.
SHE HAS NO CREDIBILITY ON THE
TOPIC.
AINSLEY: SHE’S WORRIED ABOUT
PEOPLE DYING BECAUSE OF COVID
BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL OF THE PEOPLE
DYING BECAUSE OF THE VIOLENCE ON
THE STREETS IN CHICAGO JUST THIS
WEEKEND ALONE 35 SHOT,
THREE OR  FOUR, I’VE READ FOUR
KILLED, HEARD THREE AS WELL BUT
STILL THESE ARE PEOPLE’S LIVES.
>> AINSLEY, WE HAVE HAD 185
EXPRESSWAY SHOOTINGS IN CHICAGO
THIS YEAR.
185.
THAT’S JUST THE EXPRESSWAYS.
THE VIOLENCE IS OUT OF CONTROL,
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
MAYOR KEEP TRYING TO SAY
THERE’S A DECREASE IN THE
INCREASE OF THE DECREASE.
IT IS ABSURD, AND I COULD TELL
YOU, WE KNOW, WE WILL HAVE
THOUSANDS OF OFFICERS WHO ARE
WILLING TO NOT GET PAID TO NOT
GET THE VACCINE, AND THIS ISN’T
JUST THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE LIKE SHE KEEPS HARPING ON
THIS IS THE SERGEANT’S
ASSOCIATION AND LIEUTENANT’S
ASSOCIATION AND CAPTAIN’S
ASSOCIATION UNITED IN THIS FIGHT
OUR MEMBERS SHOULD NOT BE FORCED
TO GET A MANDATED VACCINE FOR
ALL OF THE CITY WORKERS.
AINSLEY: IF THEY REFUSE TO GET
THE VACCINE HOW MANY DID YOU
SAY WILL PROBABLY BE AFFECTED?
>> YOU KNOW, WE DON’T HAVE
EXACT NUMBERS BUT IT’S ROUGHLY I
WOULD FIGURE ABOUT 3,000 IF WE
GO WITH THE INFORMAL SURVEYS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE SO FAR.
AINSLEY: IF THEY DON’T GET
VACCINATED THEY AREN’T OUT
ON THE STREETS PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY SO THE PEOPLE OF
CHI ARE AFFECTED.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND THE VIOLENCE
IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE AND
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS
LOST THE RETIREMENT AND LEAVE OF
ABSENCES TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ALMOST 900-PLUS OFFICERS SO FAR
THIS YEAR ALREADY.
WE CAN’T AFFORD MORE OFFICERS
OFF THE STREET.